welcome to this video playing
international master em western played
him a number of times that had some
quite spectacular games um okay then
chat okay he's choosing the castle
Sloane okay this is what I'm doing in
this book that I'm writing this line for
black but this is among the chapters
that it's quite a long time since I
wrote it the most dangerous way to play
as Bishop d3 c5 and then the very crude
move h4 and I'm trying that let's see
what he's doing okay g6 he knows it
obviously g6 is the best reply and of
course I've forgotten everything I knew
about it cinch five-year this is clear
but what is happening after that role I
think white is taking
I really have forgotten everything I
have forgotten absolutely everything um
okay let's just try to play and see what
what happens ok I was a bit more
concerned about 95 one thats not
necessarily does that does not
necessarily mean anything Quincy to
intending to smash on g6 mean he might
play Queenie aid may be interesting
that's also night be three I like night
be three to be honest trying to to get
stuff development for once he's got
knight c6 though will attack the e5 pawn
it's not not clear if I have time for
moose like 9 p-3 but Quincy to Queenie
eight seems ok for black ok let's let's
do that type later this really quickly
Bishop age 6 maybe maybe he will just
sacrifice the exchange or something
could be a very decent decision I don't
have anything directly write at least I
don't see it again let's do that
rucca 3 is the normal move actually rook
f7 se6 looks weird so he must take him
and well now hmm very tricky Queen takes
Knight d takes you five and remove the
Queen imitate play Bishop f5 always
temple not sure maybe even kicking
taking with the poorness the better move
well not sure at all
gym or just taking at Bishop f5 is
certainly not bad for him but of course
he can consider other things we should
be six for example all that one just
taking the the night
hmm don't really have a good move the
d2s s also had a bit to us are also
hanging of course yeah probably just
busted yeah maybe I should cancel it
looks weird but at least I love
instantly using material I think looks a
bit weird because the H file looks like
the only hope but not sure that it is
really anything realistic going on the
edge farm yeah chime morning yeah yeah
yeah I know he's changing Queens is not
really really great iam but what else
yeah don't I don't see a move really
so what is this I'm his he's got three
pawns for the exchange so it's basically
basically gone can only hope for some
silly tricks or hope that he's playing
too quickly which he does I mean all the
time but it's only a very wake up I took
yet another pawn but it's probably all
right to do that but it wasn't really
necessary the only slight hope is to
some somehow get check into the position
with the rooks looks on the seventh or
something I don't really see how this
might might happen but yeah why I waited
would ever take here at Bishop c4 check
went fishin zapcic and look at seven for
Bishop g7 check this is actually not so
easy now
well I'll just take it I mean and now I
have got some pretty substantial
discoveries going I applied that he
played their lack resigns he just
relaxed too early from this totally
winning position yeah okay as I totally
screwed up the opening forgetting
everything it is a pretty dangerous line
I mean I remember that this was my
recommendation but around here I don't
really know how how it is continued now
I do remember actually Queen c295 there
was a special do 6pm Quincy to this is
queenie eight I cannot remember I needed
to to look at burr in my my nodes yeah I
don't know maybe maybe 93 really was too
lame it's possible computer wants to
play Queen c2 with equal position yeah
okay well I'm only a pawn down and this
is this devil porn and he's got a
somewhat weakened King position the
interesting factors that the computer
wants to castle on now in tending not to
do something on the H file which
probably makes lots of sense just try to
play normally and getting getting
something back for example here once the
play Bishop b5 okay yay around here and
probably in bad shape this this looks
like a very good position for black
somehow and computer wants to take a
play ruki eight but this is just
excellent public yeah yeah I'm basically
lost
check ya bish shall be forced just the
lemon if he if he does something else
I'm just I'm just just lost him and this
is and this is even blundering a three I
can take a 3 which are also overlooked
but I was just looking at this technical
idea and it looked too tempting check
computer actually wants to take on a
three and rook f7 yeah well he can play
work GA this is what I expected actually
which is with an equal position funny
enough the computer says this is equal
with this funny line hmm he was probably
to check irritated by now he sees just
toast because of this discoveries
something check like that will probably
made in short order yeah very unlucky
window of this limb alright thanks for
watching